the University of Florida is bracing for
potential violence today at a speech by
white nationalist leader Richard Spencer
hundreds of law enforcement officers are
reporting to the Gainesville campus
before this afternoon's event Florida
Governor Rick Scott declared a state of
emergency in August Spencer participated
in a white nationalist rally in
Charlottesville Virginia that led to
deadly violence
mark Strassmann is at the University of
Florida in Gainesville mark good morning
good morning I'm standing about a half
mile from the event where Spencer will
speak because the university is keeping
everyone this far away for now that
banner spells out everything that has
banded this event from weapons to
megaphones and police are going to use
physical checkpoints and physical
barriers to keep Spencer's protesters
and supporters apart the goal here
prevent Gainesville from becoming
another Charlottesville we are hoping
that this is going to be a non-event
but we are prepared to respond and
handle this more than 5-hundred law
enforcement officers have been called in
from across the state people hailed
victory a show of force marshaled for
this afternoon's event headlined by
Richard Spencer a white nationalist
leader Sadie Darnell is the Alachua
County Sheriff what are you most worried
about Public Safety
when you get human beings together of
different opinions and then you add
emotions to it you've got the recipe for
a lot to go wrong the public safety
worried follows this deadly violence in
Charlottesville back in August
University of Florida President Kent Fox
originally rejected Spencer's plan
to speak on campus last month they
threatened to sue and then the
university's answer was yes yes why the
change we did know at that point we
weren't going to permanently ban him and
so if we could find a time and a place
when we could assure security we knew we
would allow him at that point
attorney Gary Ettinger represented
Spencer when the University of Florida
pushed back hate speech is nonetheless
protected by the Constitution as long as
it's in the realm of political speech
and not actual violence
some students plan to protest what they
consider to be hate speech others will
keep their distance
I don't feel safe me there's a limit of
color so I'll lean on my other friends
who will be out there by def we will be
inside my house the University and
president Fox stressed expressed to us
that they neither invited nor endorsed
Spencer's appearance here in fact they
really want know him not to be on campus
at all but hate speech is generally
considered protected speech and this
public university believes that it not
only has to let them in they have to pay
for the security more than five hundred
thousand dollars Jeff mark thank you
very much